[Music]
hey young Chris Craig from the android
framework team my name is Heath I also
work in the android framework team and
today we are going to talk about how to
handle large list with paging and
recyclerview
now lisa is a very common thing in
android applications
pretty much every single app has a list
of something they want to display so if
you are using architecture components
let's see how you would model a list
like this so you will have a view model
but you keep the list of items so that
it survives configuration change you
will put your data into database so that
your application works offline and of
course you have some server-side
component by you pull the data from but
usually data is dynamic it changes so to
handle these changes you will ask
database to return your live data of
list of things or an old Java observable
list of things so that you can handle
the updates for instance if you put the
updated version of two records from your
database and you insert it and then room
realizes oh there's a query observing
this table let me reveal the result
pasted over to the v-model and then your
UI can pull from the v-model and update
itself with the correct animations this
looks cool but there is actually a
problem here there's something we don't
like to better understand the issue
let's look at the interaction between
the database and the UI so when I
mentioned that database is going to
reveal the result it is going to reveal
all of the results so if you ask for the
user's order by their last name and if
you have 10,000 users is going to create
10,000 users paste it over to the UI
is very inefficient because user only
sees like eight to ten items why would
you create 10,000 items so we don't like
it we want to change this so what are we
looking for here first we like that
convenience is so nice to tell the
database give me a light date of list of
users we want the same convenience we
wanted to handle multiple layers wanna
be able to bring data from the server
put in the database and put in the UI
and this should be very easy to
implement we want it to be fast we don't
want to do any unnecessary work we don't
want it to do any big chunk of work in
the UI thread it should be efficient we
wanted to be lifecycle of air so if user
is not looking at the screen it
shouldn't do any work last but not least
we wanted to be flexible everybody has
their different back-end API is
different data structures our solution
should work with all of these things now
if we go back to our first example how
do we implement these lists if we don't
use Pejic now if you're using room in
your door you specify your query you
tell it to turn a live data of list of
users thank you in your Wemo dope you
hold a reference to it and serve it to
your UI in your activity you would use
this list activity list adapter class
but if you're not following our releases
closely you may not heard about it let's
focus on that one this adapter is a
recycle of your adapter that displays a
list so if you have the recycle of you
on the right when you called some and
this method on the adapter which just
displays it the nice thing is if you
call the same summit list method with a
different list it's going to calculate
the difference between these two lists
on a background thread
and update the UI with the correct
animations
it's available in recycler we've 27.1
and the same functionality also exists
in the asset list defer class if you
cannot extend the adapter okay let's go
back to our example we have our adapter
we observe the live data we send the
list to the adapter so for when we
initialize a little adapter we need to
give it a callback it sells to
functionalities first one it can check
if two items are equal identically and
the other one checks whether their
contents are equal or not so we can
decide whether we need to remind those
weaves or not once you have that in your
own bind we older method you can call
the get item function obtain the item in
the list and do whatever you want with
it super simple
all right so we've seen what that looks
like with a live data of list but you
also started out with this isn't good
enough so let's look at what this looks
like when you're using the new paging
library so first of all the most
important component of the pipe the
paging library is the paged list and
this is a list that implements the list
at our face but it loads data in pages
asynchronously it's backed by a class
called the data source that provides
data as the page lists needs it swaps it
in and updates the list so this serves
as a replacement for the list and all
the examples that we've done before so
let's go ahead and start swapping it out
we have this view model let's swap out
the lists with a page list and then we
go back to our Dao now what we want to
do here is you want to ask our Dao hey
can you give me a live data of a paged
list but there's actually an issue with
this so if we look over at what the data
looks like on the database side you
could imagine paging this in one way and
you could imagine paging this in a
different way it is actually some
interesting decision here are you
showing really large items are you
showing tiny items where you want to
have a lot of data paged at once well
the page size really needs to be
configurable to you know serve every
apps needs
so instead room can produce this
datasource class that backs a page list
and that way the page list can access it
and say give me item 6 through 12 and
load those data directly
into the page list now because we say
that we want multiple of them though
remember that we want something that's
observable so we just wrap that in a
factory every time that we need a new
page list out of the database we create
a new data source
all right so instead of the live data of
page list what the user Dao provides us
here is a data source factory keyed off
of integer because we're using positions
so we go back to our our view model here
and define how are we going to load this
data well it's not much code we just say
get the data source factory that we've
just declared in our user Dao and use
this live page list builder class from
the library to create a live data the
minimum amount of data that you need to
pass here is page size and here we're
passing 30 that's it now you have a live
data of page list so now all the
repository side changes are done the
view model is updated let's go to the
activity so now we were using list
adapter before well simply you change
this into a paged list adapter a page
list adapter is the exact same thing is
listed after it just happens to handle
the loading of pages as content is
internally updating in those page lists
so if we look at how we'd actually
implement this list adapter though we'd
have to switch over to the new page list
adapter and use the exact same diff call
back we don't have to change any code
there the only thing that changes is
part of implementing this on the adapter
side is that the user object becomes
nullable and we'll get into why in just
a little bit so let's go through how you
can do further configuration because we
don't stop at just page size so the the
code that we showed before of creating a
live page list builder you can simply
just pass a minimum page Sai a page size
and that's the minimum amount of data
that you need to pass but you can also
create a configuration object where you
can declare more so one thing that you
might want to do is set an initial load
size hint and this what this does is it
requests that the initial load is larger
to make that initial load avoid initial
page fetches immediately
after you you've fetched it another
thing that you can change is prefetch
distance by default this is the page
size but you can configure this if you
know that your data source is higher or
lower latency you can also control
placeholders which are an important part
of this library so let's let's start
talking about those so placeholders
false is kind of the default paging
expectations' that you might have or
typically you load the first page the
recyclerview has access to the number of
items that you've loaded and you see
well you have a big scrollbar right the
user can scroll through it and once they
get to the bottom there's no more data
once the page loads the scrollbar jumps
and the user is able to scroll forward
so we also support a completely
different type of paging here that
presents this differently if you asked
for placeholders and this is the default
in the library we will present your
lists like this you notice here that the
scrollbar is a little bit smaller and
that's because we're presenting the
entire data set to the recyclerview
immediately that scrollbar won't jump
while we're scrolling as the user
Scrolls down you see that there are
unloaded items and those are presented
as nulls in the adapter these items as
the data eventually loads display and
you'll get a nice animation for that so
let's talk about placeholders because
they don't work everywhere but we think
that they're really useful in a lot of
cases so one of the big positives of
them is that the user can scroll past
what's loaded the user doesn't have to
hit a block at the very end because you
don't have any more data yet the
scrollbar looks correct instantly and
also this is very important you can use
fast scrollers very easily because you
have the entire data set presented to
the recyclerview so you can jump
anywhere and then another nice feature
is that you don't have to implement a
loading spinner at the bottom because
the users can see the placeholder they
can see that there's like a gray icon
instead of a user icon and know that
that item is still loading there are
some downsides though of placeholders
first of all it's pretty important that
your items stay the same size if you
can't guess what the item height is
going to be before you have content for
instance if you have say a social media
post with arbitrary amount of text the
crossfade animation doesn't look great
additionally your adapter has to be able
to handle those items so that's a little
bit more code that you have to write to
say if this item doesn't exist pass my
name D string to the textview that kind
of thing
and then your data source has to be able
to count items now room can count items
out of the box but if you're using
something that is loading data from say
the network your back-end may not be
able to provide a precise count so we've
been talking a lot about our of live
data this thus far but as you introduced
at the beginning there's we also want to
support our RX Java developers so
instead of producing a live data you may
want to produce say an observable and we
provide the class rx page list builder
to do exactly that so you can change the
return type here use an rx page list
builder and then just specifically
request unobservable or a flowable out
of it and you get all the same behavior
you can use all the same code that we
were we were showing before with a
little bit of change to switch to rx
observation now let's go under the hood
because we've shown how small of a code
change this can be to switch the paging
library but how does that work
underneath ok so here on the left you
have the repository that represents the
data loading portion of your application
and then you on the right you have the
view model which is how it communicates
to the UI so inside the repository we
want to build the source for this live
data we want to produce something that
will push updates to the UI so when you
call live page list builder build we
create not only a live data that can be
used to funnel information to the UI but
the producer side as well once someone
starts observing that live data we will
create a new page list because that's
the that's the that's the way that we
start passing information down this
pipeline and to do that we create a new
data source out of the factory that we
prevail to produce now to pass this page
list over though we don't want to send
an empty list if the you I can avoid it
we would really like to load data first
and so we do that on a background thread
initialize that data and create a page
list out of it
here you can see at the very beginning
the first page list that we produce has
data only loaded at the very front we
can send that over to the UI thread and
then if you remember our submit list
call on page list adapter submits this
to the adapter and the adapter can start
immediately presenting those items now
as the user Scrolls though we might need
to load more data so the page lists
internally will trigger a data load from
its data source and append that data
directly to the page list now the
crossfade animation occurs because we
have signaled the recyclerview that
these new items are updated again but
what happens when a Content update
occurs so if the database says oh this
table has been validated something has
changed we immediately stop loading from
the data source we invalidate it so
let's look at what happens in order to
start pushing those updates though from
the other side so on the other side of
things we can see oh well the database
had an item added to it that's why we
invalidated the previous data source and
at the same time the producer side is
listening to this signal to know I need
to produce a new page list so we use
this signal to create a new data source
so that we can create a new page list to
send over and when we load the initial
data for that though we're careful to
initialize that based upon the loading
position
that was signaled by the adapter so the
user is partially scrolled down so let's
Center our load around where the user is
we send that over to the UI and now we
submit list again but because these are
two different lists and we really don't
want to call notify data set changed
what happens is that we compute an
asynchronous diff on a background thread
just like with list adapter as he'd
mentioned earlier once that diff is
computed we passed that dippers alt into
the recycler view and swap the new page
list in immediately you get a new item
showing up a new animation for that and
we only have to do the minimal amount of
UI
to bind and show the new item so
fundamentally under the hood we do a lot
of trickery to make this work but from
the outside we try and make it look as
close as possible to a live data of a
list because this is a really nice
experience it lets you keep your UI
really really simple and avoid all of
the information about paging on that
side and let you configure and construct
your your flow in one place from the
repository the page list adapter is able
to handle both the new page lists as
they flow in and also the internal
updates of the page list as it loads
okay let's talk about data sources so
mention that page this is a list
implementation that works with a data
source and we have different types of
data sources you can have a positional
data source and item keyed data source
and a page keyed data source okay let's
start with the positional data source if
you have an application like the
contacts application on Android where
you have the data locally but users may
want to jump into arbitrary positions
positional data source is your best
option this is actually what room uses
behind the scenes so if you have a data
source or UI like that you extend this
positional data source class and you
specify the type of items but to better
understand how this data source behaves
let's look at an example so we have the
UI here we'll just zoom out go to the
bird's eye view and we have our data
source on the write back by a list the
very first time you come to the recycle
Emil page this will call this load
initial method on the data source
pesticide start position a page size and
in load side initial load size which is
usually larger than the page size
because you want to have more items at
the beginning and whether placeholders
are enabled or not in this example we
just assume placeholders are enabled
so we're data source will return the
data tell us where the data starts
and it will give us a total number of
items in the data source based on that
we'll start displaying the data but
we'll also display the placeholders so
that the size of the pages is equal to
the total number of items in the data
source now user can start scrolling as
soon as you start scrolling pages will
realize that is going to run out of data
and it's going to call this load range
method on the positional data source
pass it the start position of the first
item is missing and a page size and get
the nev data appended to the list so
maybe in this case usual user uses the
fast scroller and jumps into an
arbitrary position where we didn't have
the data yet when this happens it will
call the data source load range position
we take it a position slight level
recycle Emil and load that page so that
we can display it to the user
this is why positional data source is
really good if user can jump into
arbitrary positions you never block them
let's say something has happened in the
data base data has been in well data so
we will get a Neve data source so each
data source represents a snapshot of the
data so we get this new one we'll create
a new page this for it and we'll load
the initial page from this data source
based on where user is in the previous
one we'll bring this one as always on a
background thread we will calculate the
difference between these two lists and
update the recycle area with the correct
animations second one is the item keyed
data source so in which you have some
data like a list of names if you look at
the page out of this you could identify
the items before this page by using the
first item in the list and the next page
by using the last item in the list
basically every item can identify a page
after or before it if your data sources
like that you should implement the item
keep data source cause you provide a key
type in the
case we are using names so strange and
the item type in the list okay let's
look at an example so first time you
come to the recycling wheel it's called
the load initial method pass the initial
key which is now because we don't have
it it requests the load size and whether
placeholders are enabled or not we'll
just assume they're not enabled in this
example so data source will only return
this data it's not going to count it
because there's no placeholders so start
displaying it as soon as users start
scrolling we will extract a key from the
last item we have and call the data
source load after method to load another
page similarly as user keeps scrolling
just extracts a key and then loads
another page the same way now at this
point I say this data was coming from
the database similarly something has
changed so we lost the data source spin
email dated I will get a new data source
when we create a new pages for this data
source we are going to extract the key
from one of the items that's currently
visible in the recyclerview
closer to the top and load a page from
this new data source and we get that
page we understand these are pages we
will calculate the diff and update UI
with the correct animations now we don't
take the data on top anymore so if user
tries to scroll up we need more data
same thing you just extract the key from
the first item call load before method
on the data source just get that page
prepended to the page list and now user
can scroll outwards so it's all always
lazy always reactive third one is the
page keyed data source now this is a
really common way of paging especially
on the server-side api's so your client
sends the request and when the response
comes from the server it includes the
data it also includes pointers for the
next and pre
get up API works this way reddit API
works this way is very common so if you
have a data source like that you should
implement the page key data source
specify the type of your keys that you
use in the pointers and the item type
okay let's look at an example first time
user comes to the UI we call load
initial we give it a size and we ask
whether placeholders are enabled or not
they're usually disabled because your
server doesn't give you an accurate
count we'll just assume they're disabled
easier and then the data source returns
the data but it also gives us pointers
for the previous key and the next page
key and then we start displaying it if
user Scrolls
we need more content so we're going to
call the load after method use the key
that was returned in the previous
request to get the next page from the
data source now this next page comes
with a field called adjacent page key so
it always sells okay what is the next
page in this direction is literally like
a linked list of pages once you take
that user can scroll now a difference in
this data source is how we handle
invalidation median user hit the refresh
button on the screen data sources in
well data will get a new data source but
in the lord initial method there is no
key anymore
this is because I mentioned it's like a
linked list so if the previous list is
invalid links in the list doesn't mean
anything so you always need to load the
very first page again and display it in
the UI this is usually not a problem in
practice because you only do this if
user does swipe the Refresh so they are
already on top of the list okay alright
so you talk through what we might see
implementing a data source but what
happens when we
load from multiple sources at once so a
database plus Network solution these two
components can work really nicely
together when the database acts as a
cache for the network you can page from
your back-end that you have with all the
benefits of the local cache you can have
a really nice offline support you can
resume quickly if the application has
been killed and restarted and you can
minimize network traffic by taking
advantage of data that's already on
device so let's look at what how this
might look compared to what we were we
were showing before with a single source
of data so how does the network fit into
this system so one way that we could do
this is we could basically say well the
network is my source of data when I'm
connected and the database is my source
when I'm not so if I'm connected then I
iPage data from the network and if I'm
not I page data from the database the
one problem there is that you don't have
anything storing data in your database
even when you're loading a network but
it's pretty easy as a side effect of
loading from the network you can just
store in the database and there you have
paging from both however this has a
couple of really big problems that are
important to discuss so this switching
model has the first problem that this
connected state is really
oversimplifying in reality individual
requests to your servers can succeed and
fail and a user that's connected like
20% some of the packets go through that
doesn't really fit really nicely into
this model or the other big problem is
that we're not using local data when
it's present so let's go about looking
at a different way to do this so what if
instead we just monitor the database and
use that as our local single source of
truth what we can do then is we can say
well the only time that I need to load
data is when the database tells me that
it's out of data I can use that as a
signal to load more data from the
network store it into the database and
then I have my entire solution built I
just load data when I need to but I can
present only the database which makes
things a lot simpler so we get the
benefits of consistent data for
we have a similarly simple process but
importantly this gracefully de creatives
on failures if your can if your user is
in that 20% connected state you can
still produce you can still present all
of the data that you have locally and
try and fetch or potentially retry when
the network is around so potentially you
might say well this doesn't keep my data
fresh and an easy way to work around
that is to just say whenever anyone
starts observing this stream of data we
we start a new fetch we we see if we
need to to refresh our content and
that's especially important usually when
you have frequently updating data so in
so in that proposed model here that we
saw we need an out of data signal from
the database because the rest of that
we've basically already built in the
first few slides so when we have that
signal we can trigger loads from the
network directly into the database and
the UI doesn't have to enter into any of
that
so paging built exactly this signal for
exactly this reason and we call that the
boundary callback so let's go ahead and
look at what that might look like so the
first most important part of the
boundary callback that you that you
implement is that you pass it two
different that you'll want to provide it
two different sources of data the
database and the network because that's
its job so the first that the important
callback that we have here is on item it
unloaded and this signifies the last
item in the database has been loaded
from the paged list and if there's more
from the network it's time to load it so
the first thing that we do in response
to this is that we over on a network
thread we can request our service hey
give me more data and in this particular
case we're using the item at the end to
feed which data we need more of because
we're in an item keyed case similar to
the item keyed data source that you saw
before now if that request is successful
we simply jump over to the database
thread insert that data that we loaded
from the response into the database and
we're basically done we've we've
connected that signal that we needed and
now we've added network to something
that was purely
to base now the one other trick that you
need to need to be aware of though is
that it's possible when the database is
being invalidated locally for multiple
at end signals to trigger so what you
can do is you can just protect this with
a simple boolean to say if I'm already
loading don't try and then we can reset
that at the end so using this boundary
callback is pretty simple you can just
add this back into your live page list
builder or to your rx page list builder
and then that gives you the database
plus Network solution all isolated in
that one callback so let's talk about
what the paging library is so the paging
library provides paging from database
Network and importantly both as we just
saw and it can load that data directly
into recyclerview
it extends this live data of list this
observable list pattern that we really
like because it keeps our UI incredibly
simple and it lets us contain all of the
complex logic on one side it's
configurable we have configurable load
size prefetch and placeholders and it
integrates directly with room with live
data and with rx the paging 1.0 was just
released and so please give it a try
take it for a spin
hi that was a lot of information we know
so where to go next well we have
extensive documentation on the web
render it calm so we can just read we
provide more details and more samples
there we have an amazing code lab you
can just check it out in the code lab
area or you can try it online we also
have samples on github where we
implement different data sources using
reddit API or a different local database
and you can compare and contrast the
behavior of different data sources you
can also see how you could handle things
or like errors retries we are all of it
there but if you be sitting here for the
last 30 minutes I'm wondering whether
these two guys never heard about cursors
and its built-in PageRank
lest they should be dead hear about that
so this is actually what we wanted to
use initially when we started this
project because we already have cursor
adapter the cursor it takes care of all
the work right wrong so we realize it is
very unpredictable and inefficient if
your cursor becomes large so especially
if your in your application currently if
you are using cursor for lazy loading be
very careful room and paging together
avoids this problem because we create
much smaller queries not to rely on the
paging behavior of cursors now it's a
very complex topic but Chris wrote an
amazing blog post about this that you
can watch in that link and we will post
this URL after the talk it's amazing but
TLDR cursors paging is not the right way
to the paging we did it wrong we awful
if he said this time did it wrong ten
years ago at least 10 years ago it's not
me okay okay so paging is part of
jetpack our new initiative to accelerate
Android development
we had great many talks at this i/o this
was the last one so please if you were
not able to attend those sessions check
them on YouTube everything is recorded
and goes to learn more about jetpack on
our website and provide us feedback
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]